jigsaw is the unforgettable villain in
the source series but he's not just a
creepy puppet
he's a deeply disturbed man whose morals
are as warped as they are eerily
understandable
this is the story of john kramer billy
the puppet
and where it all began there's no doubt
that jigsaw's life took a deeply dark
turn
yet before he became jigsaw john kramer
led a genuinely upright life
as civil engineer kramer was utterly
dedicated to making cities better places
to live with his business partner a
lawyer named art blank
he started a foundation with the goal of
creating affordable housing for working
families
the foundation's first major project was
a meat packing plant
this was presumably undertaken to
provide jobs for blue-collar workers in
new york city
but this planted a far darker destiny it
would become a base of operations for
jon
after he became a serial murderer
unsurprisingly
jigsaw took full advantage of the plan's
capacity for grotesque horror
we often imagined serial killers as
extreme loners however
john kramer is very much the opposite he
was a man of and for the people
and he lived a relatively
straightforward life until it all went
wrong
prior to becoming jigsaw he married jill
turk his charitable nature rubbed off on
his wife
who kramer convinced to open up the
homewood-bound clinic aimed at helping
drug addicts recover and build new lives
jill worked at the clinic all through
her pregnancy with their first child
who kramer hoped to name gideon
alongside her team of nurses
jill helped people hoping to kick their
opiate addictions and she did so with
kindness
strength and perseverance though he
encouraged her to start the clinic
kramer's increasing sense of the danger
of jill's job began to weigh on him
particularly as her pregnancy progressed
much of kramer's pre-jigsaw life would
extend into his career as a serial
killer
the knowledge he'd gained as an engineer
and builder would eventually come to
fruition in his infamous and deadly
contraptions
in time john kramer met a man named
willian easton at a party thrown at the
clinic
easton was the head of umbrella
insurance and he revealed an algorithm
his company used to distribute care
essentially placing a concrete value on
each individual human life
everybody thinks we're the bad guys
nobody mentions the millions of people
we help every year
without incident kramer was horrified
both by the concept and the variables
eastern used he thought that the
equation was faulty because it didn't
take into account a patient's will to
live
this was a brutal lesson in the
mathematics of morality one that would
leave kramer forever changed
kramer became more and more uneasy about
jill's workplace and with good reason
one night at the clinic as he waited to
pick up his wife kramer got between two
patients about to come to blows one of
the men
cecil adams pulled a knife on john
kramer was able to successfully talk
adams down
convincing him to drop the knife and
even managing to deliver a lecture
on how one's mistakes can spiral out of
control and affect society at large
despite kramer's warning cecil adams
returned to the clinic
where he threatened jill with a knife
and forced her to open the door
he backed the visibly pregnant gillip
against the wall and commanded her to
stay put while he stole supplies of
methadone
leaving with the stolen medication cecil
accidentally hit jill in the stomach
jill began to bleed and collapse to the
floor realizing that he may have hurt
jill's unborn child
cecil ran from the clinic kramer was
waiting out front to pick up his wife
when he saw cecil leaving in a panic he
ran in to see if anyone was hurt
jon found his wife bleeding out on the
floor and took her to a nearby hospital
jill and john's first child gideon had
been lost they were utterly devastated
and would never attempt to have another
child
gideon's death took john to a dark place
he began refusing to see his wife or go
to work
he abandoned his mission to build
housing for the needy his withdrawal
from the world was so complete that
neither jill nor kramer's business
partner art blank
knew where to find him they finally
found john in his workshop where he had
been building billy the puppet
blank urged kramer not to walk away from
the needy families they had helped
kramer was blank argued their savior
and they needed him now more than ever
sadly kramer was unmoved
jill delivered a parting blow telling
jon that she suffered as much if not
more from gideon's death she separated
from jon soon after
after splitting from jill jon began to
deteriorate
cramer was diagnosed with colon cancer
and an additional tumor in the frontal
lobe of his brain and started
chemotherapy
however he was late in beginning his
treatment as one of the hospital's
residents accidentally mixed up his
imaging results with another patient
his name is john dr gordon
he's a very interesting person
by the time the tumor in kramer's brain
was discovered the doctors believed it
to be inoperable
as a result kramer desperately began to
seek out experimental cancer treatments
the clock was ticking and the odds were
against him
kramer needed approval from his medical
insurance companies undergo a radical
cancer treatment in norway he attended a
meeting with william easton the
insurance executive would previously
shaken cramer with his brutal
monetization of human life
easton claimed he couldn't cover
kramer's healthcare costs based on the
aforementioned algorithms umbrella
insurance used in all cases
as eastern explained in their earlier
meeting the company determined whether
or not a patient's health was a good
investment before making a decision
kramer was not considered to be a good
investment
fully convinced that he was going to die
john kramer made the decision to end his
own life
he drove off of a cliff but to his shock
he lived to tell the tale
john emerged from the crash feeling
invigorated despite his injuries
the true brush with death had made him
realize how precious life really was
kramer began to think that other people
could do with a near-death experience of
their own
he believed that if he could make people
come to faith with their own deaths
they might learn to appreciate their
lives as a result he began devising his
special games and contraptions
and started operating under his alter
ego jigsaw alongside his tricycle riding
sidekick
billy the puppet a horror icon was born
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one